The disparity in quality going from Secret
Invasion to Loki Season 2 gave me insane whiplash.
On one hand, we have a terribly executed mess
that had a crisis behind the scenes, and then
on the other, we have a triumph in storytelling
that tells a singular and spectacular vision
for a loveable character.
Because that’s why Loki works so well over
so many of these other projects.
It has a deeply engaging story that has a
thoroughly evolving main character.
Loki at the start of the show and to the end
of season 2 are practically opposite characters
and that kind of journey, written in a compelling
manner is amazing.
This is going into what I think is by far
the best aspect of Loki season 2 which is
Eric Martin’s writing of characters, their
journeys, and their internal conflicts.
Everyone on the roster besides maybe one or
two characters have fully fleshed out arcs
with tangible motivations that make them riveting
and likable characters.
This is what I would identify as Marvel’s
major issue in that most character work has
taken a back seat as they prioritize screen
time in other areas.
Recent examples being in Ant-Man Quantumania
where Scott and Cassie’s relationship feels
very shallow and in The Marvels, Carol Danvers’
primary internal conflict is wholly underdeveloped.
Then when you look at Marvel’s recent great
movies like Guardians of the Galaxy 3 and
No Way Home, they tell engrossing stories
that are primarily driven by their ever evolving
characters.
Loki Season 2 I think falls right into that
category of greatness because of how excellent
its character work is.
Loki’s villain to hero arc is a really hard
thing to pull off because it requires a complex
dive into the psyche of his character.
He goes from someone who desperately tried
to grasp at control and purpose in his life
through any form of evil means, all the way
to someone who only accepts power out of sheer
necessity of doing the right thing.
And since this was done in a show setting,
it gave the creators enough time to fully
explore this rich character arc to its full
potential.
We actually have long and intriguing dialogue
scenes that are imbued with important revelations
for our characters.
Like most dialogue scenes between two characters
generally lead to one of them changing immensely.
Examples being Loki sparking the interest
of what Mobious’ life was like outside of
the TVA, Loki’s talk with Sylvia in which
she learns that purely destroying something
want solve problems, and Mobius driving in
the final nail to Loki’s arc in that one’s
purpose is primarily burden over glory, and
the burden is inevitable.
Delivering Loki’s final revelation in that
he has to become a time god and be burdened
with taking care of the entire multiverse.
A truly selfless act.
These are just a few examples, but every episode
is packed full of these incredible dialogue
scenes.
Now some are obviously better than others
and I’ll get into what I think are some
of the show’s faults towards the latter
half of the video, but the batting average
is still really high.
So much to the point that it’s admirable
that primarily character and dialogue-driven
scenes carry this show so much.
Like looking at any other Marvel show, they
generally have to interject some kind of artificial
action to make the episode more exciting.
However, Loki doesn’t need to do this because
of how high-quality the drama is in the show.
Easily the best and most refreshing climax
in any Marvel show is the showdown between
He Who Remains and Loki and Sylvie.
There’s no crazy spectacle or action setpiece
to entertain the audience and it’s purely
dialogue.
And Loki season 2 somehow elevates it and
adds an additional layer onto that finale
from the first season.
I honestly was kind of skeptical going into
the finale of Loki season 2, but it far and
away exceeded my expectations.
The second finale confrontation with He Who
Remains really reminds me of the final showdown
between Sherlock Holmes and Moriarty.
In that movie, they are playing these complex
mindgames where they are constantly countering
each other.
And with the season 2 finale, it reveals He
Who Remains’ true plan in that he knew Loki
would end up coming back to stop Sylvie because
of the loom’s failsafe in destroying all
of time.
It actually makes He Who Remains a more evil
character because it seems like he did this
out of pure boredom.
He knew the outcome would inevitably end the
way it would and he’s doing this to torture
Loki in that he now has to kill someone he
cares about to save all of time.
However, like in Sherlock Holmes, this action
made by the villain that comes across as seemingly
being a checkmate can actually be countered
by our hero.
This is the kind of writing that is outstanding
in which the viewer doesn’t know a logical
way in overcoming the conflict and the hero
has to come up with something that is clever.
For Loki, his solution to He Who Remains’
conundrum isn’t just a clever solution,
but it’s also an integral step for Loki
in finishing his character arc.
It ironically acts as a lay-up of sorts for
Loki in finding his glorious purpose and finishing
his ultimate redemption arc.
Overcoming conflict is one thing, but if you
can also make it expertly tie into the main
character’s arc, then that is great writing.
Which is what Eric Martin achieves here.
Along with the monumental task of creating
an hour worth of riveting dialogue which is
essentially what the ending is.
It just requires a lot more skill and artistry
to write something of this caliber over something
like the Wandavision finale which feels significantly
more convoluted and messy narratively.
And I’m being generous bringing that up
as a comparison because that’s one of the
better ones.
Also for the season 2 finale, I love how they
essentially turned half of the episode into
Groundhogs Day which is one of my favorite
movies, but applied it to a hardcore science
fiction setting.
Seeing Loki ram his head into a wall trying
to overcome this mind-boggling conflict was
incredibly engrossing.
It would have been nice if the finale was
longer because I feel like the writers downplayed
the mental impact of doing the same thing
over and over for centuries, but it was still
well executed.
Maybe Loki is more resilient to long stretches
of time because he is a god after all.
So Loki’s character arc is obviously outstanding
and the other two main side characters, being
Mobius and Sylvie are also great of course.
Mobius and Loki’s dynamic is still very
endearing and the writers lean into that even
more for season 2.
At times it did feel a little forced, an example
being Mobius leaving during a fight scene
to go find a bike with two seats for him and
Loki, while in other moments it felt more
natural.
As long as the writers weren’t going out
of their way for any shenanigans, I felt like
it was fine.
But for Mobius overall, I think it was pretty
genius in that the writers were able to showcase
his entire life on the timeline while also
building Loki’s character in overcoming
time slipping.
It was very efficient and offered a significant
amount of value for Mobius as a character
as we got to witness his entire backstory.
And the same thing applies for the other more
minor side characters.
Like up until episode 5, I was kind sad that
Ke Huy Quan’s character OB was basically
just a character that rattled off complicated
exposition, but episode 5 fleshes him out
and makes him more understandable as a character.
And not just a vessel to explain different
mechanics within the world.
Because he’s honestly just a downgraded
version from his character in Everything Everywhere
All at Once, however, I think episode 5 luckily
redeems him.
Sylvie I think has a good continuation and
her arc of slowly defusing from a destructionist
mentality was really well done and explored.
Her final scene with Loki was heartfelt and
perfectly punctuates the ending of her arc
in aiding Loki in realizing that destroying
something is OK if you replace it with something
better.
Now for the last character I’ll address
that I don’t think was very well done was
Renslayer.
It feels like her villain arc was nowhere
near as complex as the other characters in
the show.
Because she essentially just wants power and
to control the TVA even though she’s literally
causing the TVA’s downfall by delaying Mobius
and Loki in fixing the loom.
I know she doesn’t trust them, but it feels
like a contradiction in that she wants to
restore the TVA to it’s former glory while
also being the one that’s causing its downfall.
I guess there is some irony there even though
it doesn’t feel very logical from a character
point of view.
Outside of her lust for power, there’s really
nothing else about her to make her fascinating.
The revelation about her mind being wiped
I thought was a good twist for the character,
but it again only feeds into that lust for
power.
So if anything, it kind of feels like Renslayer
was used as a roadblock conflict in drawing
out the story until the loom explodes because
without her the show would be much shorter.
Which this is fine, I just wish she was more
compelling.
Her state in the show was pretty underwhelming
considering how much screen time she had and
especially how abrupt her ending was.
The writers were kind of like, oh yeah and
by the way Renslayer dies after being sent
to the void, that’s it.
Then her and Miss Minutes’ lust towards
Victor Timely was very odd and off-putting
to the point that it was not needed at all.
So even though Renslayer was partially lacking,
I think Loki season 2’s characters were
still outstanding all around.
Another aspect that goes hand and hand with
the characters is the acting.
Out of the entire MCU, I think Tom Hiddleston
is easily the best actor.
The amount of range and raw emotion that is
constantly required for the character in every
scene is flooring.
It obviously helps that the writing allows
this, but there are so many beautiful close-ups
of Loki throughout the season in which he
puts you in a trance with his amazing acting.
Tom Hiddleston has a mastery understanding
of everything whether it being subtlety, gravitas,
charisma, pacing, great delivery of lines,
and nails sorrow with ease.
He’s literally a flawless actor and it’s
rare to be this consistently floored.
I know that acting awards for the Emmys is
extremely crowded from how many great shows
are running, but it would honestly feel like
a snub if Tom Hiddleston doesn’t get a Best
Lead Actor nomination.
Unfortunately, though, I feel like voters
will automatically look past this show just
because of the Marvel brand not being what
it used to be.
Without Tom Hiddleston, this show would be
practically nothing and he perfectly sells
the anguish and turmoil Loki as a character
is constantly going through.
Then other standouts I would say are definitely
Jonathan Majors and Sophia Martino.
I know all the controversy around Jonathan
Majors is bad, but that doesn’t take away
from the fact he did a great job in season
2.
At first, I found Victor Timely to be kind
of annoying, but his wholesomeness quickly
grew on me and I loved how Jonathan got to
revisit He Who Remains again.
Sophia Martino like Tom Hiddleston delivers
deeply emotional moments with ease and they
always make a great pairing.
It’s just a little unfortunate she wasn’t
as heavily featured in season 2, but that’s
fine since that’s what made sense for the
story.
Then other actors who weren’t as prominent
in the story still did a great job.
One of my favorite examples is the scene where
all the prisoners get killed and the filmmakers
decide to only show the reactions of both
Wunmi and Rafael who perfectly mirror the
horror they’re witnessing.
Now I’ll go into one more great aspect about
Loki season 2 before going into some faults
I had with the season.
And the last great thing I want to dive into
is the production value of the show.
Loki easily blows every other MCU production
out of the water because this is the only
show that actually feels like a show.
They’re constructing numerous real sets
that are re-used instead of constantly going
to random locations to film scenes that are
in turn in dull locations because they’re
only used once.
Building these sets also probably saves them
quite a bit of money so that they can then
spend it on making the CGI look great.
Because throughout the show it looked pretty
spectacular and I especially loved the spaghetti
unraveling of people being erased from time.
It visually looked cool and was creative.
The only CGI moment that was very odd was
actually the very beginning of season 2 where
Loki jumps off of the TVA tower and lands
into a flying car.
This shot immediately scared me from how rough
it looked, as if a beginner in blender made
it, but luckily it gets way better.
I would say that the moment right after this
where a practical car crashes into a real
set redeems the janky-looking shot.
But yeah, the overall visual look of the show
is of such a high quality and has a strong
visual identity because of its unique and
exotic locations.
Similar obviously to season 1, even though
I would argue that season 1 visually was more
memorable than season 2.
There is an entirely different cinematographer
and different directors that in turn make
the show feel different visually, but I still
think it looks good.
I don’t think the vast majority of viewers
will notice a major shift, although, to me,
the first season looked a bit more dramatic
in terms of its lighting for different scenes.
While season 2 feels more loose and is directed
and shot with an ensemble of characters taken
into account.
So going into what I think is the main fault
of the season, and I know this video is titled
as being a triumph of a show, but I don’t
think season 2 is a flawless 10/10.
The first half of the season in comparison
to the latter half I think is weaker and there
are a few reasons for this.
Firstly, the plot of episodes 2 and 3 were
primarily sub-plots that were there to buy
time until the ending of the show.
Now you may immediately disagree with that
assessment so let me explain.
In episode 2, Loki and Mobius spend half of
the episode questioning Brad about where Sylvie
is and also uncover a sudden conflict that
there are loyalists killing branching timelines.
There’s not a lot of set-up for this development,
especially for Brad’s character.
It feels as though we skipped over an episode
as this random background character becomes
an integral centerpiece out of nowhere.
So you spend half the time confused as to
if you missed something and why were spending
so much time with him.
Then after this conflict is resolved, the
leader of these loyalists becomes irrelevant
within the story as Renslayer comes in to
kill her.
Now is the writing for these scenes bad by
any means?
Absolutely not.
It just doesn’t feel like an efficient usage
of time in terms of storytelling.
There is some importance for this episode
in that it ropes Sylvie back into the narrative,
they’re able to find Renslayer and establishes
Brad as a character, but I can’t help but
escape the feeling that we're just spending
time on a sub-plot for this episode.
And the same thing applies for episode 3.
I know Victor Timely is a pretty important
character, but the writers only make him that
way because they randomly require the creator’s
aura to unlock the blast doors.
The writers only do this to give Victor Timely
importance within the narrative because, besides
that, he doesn’t really offer anything to
the story.
He helps out with some scientific problem-solving,
but that’s kind of a minor point that you
can just write to have OB think of.
So for episode 3, we essentially have this
entire artificial side-quest to get a character
who has random importance because the writers
willed it to happen.
Now again, the time spent here in the show
doesn’t mean it was bad.
Just in comparison to the latter half of season
2 which features a clean and efficient narrative,
the first half feels inferior.
The writers still include solid character
development and overall well-written scenes,
so I think it partially alleviates this fault.
Also, I think it could have been a narrative
upgrade if they had Mobius be the one who
goes out on the catwalk in episodes 4 and
6 instead of Victor.
Mobius’ loss at the end of episode 4 would
be much more of a motivator for Loki because
Mobius is like his best friend.
Along with having much higher stakes because
we as an audience care more about Mobius rather
than a character who just showed up.
That and imagine how much more of a gut-punch
the ending to episode 4 would be if we thought
Mobius died.
So in an overall sense, I don’t think Victor
Timely ultimately added a lot to the story
and could have been removed from it without
much loss being felt.
And I feel like I have to keep bringing this
up in which I’m not knocking the quality
of episodes 2 and 3 and just the relevance
and importance to the main plot.
Since there are only 6 episodes within the
season, spending time on subplots is felt
even more because the story is already short.
This in comparison to season 1, where every
episode was extremely productive in progressing
the main story, starts to feel like a stark
contrast.
Which speaking of this comparison, I think
season 1 of Loki is a bit stronger because
of the fact that each episode thoroughly engages
you from a plot perspective.
What I mean by this is that every episode
hooks you with a captivating mystery as we
keep going further down this alluring rabbit
hole of a story.
Like figuring out what the TVA is, finding
out that we are hunting a variant whose a
Loki, the Loki variant being a girl and her
actually being kind of a protagonist, the
timekeepers being fake, overcoming the void
and Goliath, and meeting He Who Remains and
getting answers to all of our questions.
Season 1 is utterly packed to the brim with
an engaging and fun plot that it kind of makes
season 2 seem underwhelming in comparison.
Where in season 2 the plot is basically just
trying to fix the loom with a couple subplots
interjected to make the season longer.
I wouldn’t say this is very bad because
the narrative still hits an absolute high
point for the finale.
Just it’s kind of a shame that the first
half of the season doesn’t really match
the high quality of the second half of the
season.
So that’s really the only main flaw I had
with season 2 that brought it down slightly
and there were also occasionally some weird
moments in terms of writing.
Like the surreal scene where Victor insists
upon going to get a cup of coffee where Brad
kills Soap and kidnaps Victor.
That was honestly one of the weirdest and
most contrived scenes in the entire show that
it felt jarring watching that scene in an
otherwise great episode.
Then another contrived moment that stood out
to me was Sylvie sending Renslayer to the
end of time instead of killing her.
Like she didn’t even take her tempad and
I thought she was intending her being stuck
there as a fate being worse than death.
But yeah, every now and then the writing falters
and the tone can feel a bit weird at times
like Victor’s chase scene in episode 3,
but I think the average quality of season
2 is high enough to the point that these sudden
quality shifts aren’t a major deal.
That and the ending is so amazing that you
can forgive some of the show’s faults.
So overall, Loki season 2 even though I’d
say is a minor downgrade from season 1, is
still far and away better than basically anything
Marvel has produced in the last few years.
This is the bar of quality that I wish the
MCU can regularly operate in.
It’s kind of unfortunate that Disney is
also releasing The Marvels at the same time
as the finale of Loki season 2.
So they’re essentially overshadowing something
they made that’s great, with something that’s
bad.
That just seems baffling to me that they would
do that.
But thank you for watching.
My Letterboxd, Patreon, and Discord links
are in the description, and I also just did
a review on The Marvels if you want to check
that out too.